[موسيقى]
شكرا لك ياعمار قالت وكاله الاناضول انه
هجوما بي اربعه مقذوفات وقع في منطقه
قرقميش التابعه لولايه غزه عتاب جنوبيه
تركيا واضافت الوكاله ان هذه القذائف التي
اطلقتها الوحدات الكرديه كان مصدرها شمالي
سوريا واصابه مناطق خاليه غير ماهوله
وكاله وسائل اعلام رسميه تركيه قد قالت ان
قصر صاروخيا على معبر بونجو بنار الهدودي
المقابل معبر باب السلامه السوري تركيا
هذا وقال وزير الدفاعي تركي خلصي اكار الى
ضربات الجويه التي نفذتها القوات التركيه
على مواقع في منطقه عين العرب شمال شرقي
سوريا وفي شمال العراق نجحت في تدمير
مواقع ومقار لمسلحي حزب العمال الكردستاني
ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه التي وصفتهم
بالمنظمات الارهابيه
التي تعود للارهابيين وتعقبنا ذلك عن كتب
وتم تدميره مقر تابعي للمنظمه الارهابيه
كما تم استهدافه الارهابيين والمواقع التي
تخصهم فقط ومخلب القوات المسلحه
الارهابيين مره اخرى ولدينا القدره
والاصرار على انقاذ بلدنا وشعبنا من بلاء
الارهاب المتسلط عليهم منذ 40 عاما ولم
نترك ابدا تاره شهدائنا ومواطنين
سوريا والعراق اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه
قصفها مشدده على انها مواقع عسكريه لما
سمته تنظيمات الارهابيه واللافته وتوزع
جغرافيا هذه المواقع على امتداد الحدود
المشتركه لتركيا مع هذين البلدين نتعرف
على ابرز هذه الاهداف في هذا التقرير
بنجاح تمت عمليه عسكريه شماليه سوريا
والعراق تحت اسم المخلب السيف هكذا تقول
تركيا ردا على تفجير اجابه الاستقلال في
اسطنبول الاسبوع الماضي تتحدث انقره عن
تدمير نحو 90 هدفا تابعا لمواصفاتها
بالتنظمه الارهابيه في اشاره الى قوه حزب
العمال الكردستاني والقوات الموليه له وفي
التفاصيل اشاره وزاره الدفاع التركيه الى
تنفيذ مقاتلات تركيه سلسله من القاره على
مواقع عسكريه شمال شرقي سوريا وفي شمال
العراق واشارت مصادر اعلاميه الى ان
الاهداف مواقع عسكريه لما تعرفوا بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه في كل من تل رفعت
وعندنا في حلب وشمال عين عيسى في الرقه
ومناطق في الحسكه وعين العرب كوباني على
الحدود السوريه
بينما نقلت رويترز عن متحدث باسم ما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه التي تشكل وحدته
حمايه الشعب الكرديه العمود هل في قريه ان
طائره تركيه قصفت قريتين ماهوولتين
بالنازحين في شمال سوريا اما وكاله
الانباء السوريه الرسميه فتحدثت عن مقتل
اعاده من الجنود يترهجمه تركيا قالت انها
استهدفت مواقع في ريفي حلب والحسكه
جغرافيا الهجمات التركيه طالت ايضا وفق
تصريحات لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مناطق
سنجار وكاراكولوس والقنديل واسوس شمالي
العراق بينما تحدثت وسائل اعلام سوريا عن
قصف القوه الكوريه برجمه الصواريخ محيطه
معبر باب السلامه على الحدود التركيه
بالقرب من مدينه اعزاز بريف حلب اما وكاله
تركيه
بوقوع اصابه جراه هجوم صاروخين على منطقه
قرب بوابه حدوديه في اقليم كنيسه تركيه من
الحدود مع سوريا تطورات الميدانيه تاتي
بينما وعدت ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه بالرد على الضرابه الجويه
التي شنتها تركيا عدم واقعها
[موسيقى]
معي من انقر يوسف لابارده الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي التركي ومن همبرج حسين
جلابيه الباحث في الشان الكردي اهلا بكم
ابدا بضيف من انقذ السيد يوسف انا بارده
واسالك يعني بدايه بهذه التطورات وسقوط
هذه
الصواريخ التي تم اطلاقها من شمال سوريا
في الاراضي التركيه وان كانت وقعت في
مناطق خاليه ولكن كيف تجديد هذا الرد او
هذه الرساله
اعداد
من الهجمات الارهابيه التي تستهدف تركيا
ليست الاولى من نوعها وتركيا واجهتها في
السابق وهذا يحصل تقريبا في كل يوم ولكن
هذا يحصل بعد القذف الجوي التركي
ام هو استمرار لما جرى في الاشهر والسنوات
الماضيه تركيه تتهم التنظيمات الكرديه
بتنفيذ ما تسميه عمليه ارها ثم ترد بهذه
الطريقه
للعمليه
بالنسبه الى القوات التركيه اذا هناك
عمليات بدات
يمكننا ان نتحدث عن ثلاث عمليات في داخل
السوريه بسبب الهجمات الارهابيه وليس فقط
الهجمات الارهابيه ولكن ايضا هناك اربعه
ملايين لاجئ في داخل تركيا وهذا ما يدفع
تركيا لتحقيق الاهداف السياسيه ويمكن
تحقيق هذه الاهداف الى حد ما من خلال
العمليات العسكريه فيما بعد ذلك هذه
العمليات العسكريه ليست حلا للازمه في
سوريا ولكن الى حد ما هي ضروريه لان
الحدود التركيه تخطر اكثر من خلال الهجمات
الارهابيه من سوريا ومن العراق لذلك
السياسه الخارجيه التركيه تقضي بمكافحه
الارهاب من الداخل الى الخارج
طبعا من هامبورج سيد حسين الجلبي ما الذي
تحققه هذه التنظيمات ال- اا كرديه طبعا
بناء على الروايه
بانها تنفذ ما تصفها بعمليات ارهابي للاسف
فقدنا الاتصال بضيفي من همبرج السيد حسين
جلبسا سوف نحاول ال- ال- التكرار الاتصال
به لذلك اعود الى ضيفه
لاساله عن
امكانيه ان تتوسع هذه العمليات من قبل
الجانب التركي
وماذا عن البعد الامريكي في الذي يثبت
نوعا ما رد الفعل التركي الى الان كما
يقال
اي كان سيدات
العمليات العسكريه تهدف الى تحقيق الهدف
السياسي الهدف السياسي بنسبه الى تركيا
ليس احتلال الاراضي فقط نتحدث عن منطقه
امنه بمساحه 30 كلم
لوقف الهجمات التي تاتي من الداخل السوري
لاننا نتحدث عن دولتين
امنا لكل المنظمات الارهابيه بما في ذلك
حزب العمال الكردستاني وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه وداع عاش ولذلك خسرنا
لذلك من وجهه نظري هدف تركيا السياسيه يجب
ان يتحقق من خلال فتح الحوار واذا ما لم
يؤدي ذلك الى نتيجه يجب تامين هذه المنطقه
الامنه من خلال استخدام القوه الصلبه من
هامبورج اذا ما قدمنا الصوره كما يقولها
الجانب التركي دوله تحارب منظمات تصفها
بالارهابيه وبالتالي ما الذي تحققه هذه
المنظمات من خلال ما تقوم به في ظل هذه
الضربات القويه المتتاليه من قبل الجانب
الكردي التركي عفوا
مساء الخير مساء النور
كامله اولا ابارك لقدر نجاحها في افتتاح
كاس العالم
يعني بالتوفيق في المباريات القادمه كنت
اتمنى ان يكون هذا اليوم يوم سلام تتوقف
فيه المدافع في جميع انحاء العالم ولكن
للاسف الشديد للمقاتلين للمتقاتلين راي
اخر همم هنالك يعني همم في المناطق
الكرديه السوريه وفي مناطق شمالي اقليم
كردستان العراق لا يوجد انهم مستقل لان
نعلم حقيقه اذا كانت تركيا قد حققت
اهدافها كما تقول الاعلام يسيطر عليه حزب
العمال الكردستاني وهو لديه روايه واحده
ينشرها دائما لا نعلم فيما اذا كانت همم
تركيا من جهتها قامت بنشر صور لي العمليه
وقالت بناء حققت ادافه ولكن كما ذكرتم كان
هنالك رد بعد ساعات على همم العمليه
العسكريه التركيه همم هنالك اعتقاد لدى
الكردما بان حزب العمال الكردستاني
منخرت حقيقه في اجنده معاديه لهم او يمكن
لتركيا حل القضيه بطرق اخرى غير الطريقه
العسكريه اا يعني هنالك اتصالات
استخباراتيه بين المخابرات التركيه
والمخابرات السوريه وحزب العمال
الكردستاني متعاون متحالف مع نظام الاسد
لذلك همم
يعني قصف المنطقه من بعيد علاوه
قد يحقق او قد لا يحقق
نتائجها ولكن هنالك اضرار تصيب المدنيين
والمدنيين هم ضحايا الحسين ولم يحدث هذا
من قبل طبعا باشارتك للحل السياسي الجانب
التركي فتح المجال السياسي طبعا لاكراد
همم تركيا واصبح جزء في البرلمان ثم
انقلب الامر بشكل مختلف بالتالي كيف يمكن
تصور الحال في ظل هذه المعادله الشائكه
سيد حسين
لعلي اين فقط الاتصال به مره اخرى لاعود
الى السيد ضيف السيد يوسف الابار
القدس سالتك عن البعد الامريكي مباشره بعد
عمليه اسطنبول وزير الداخليه التركي عبر
عن الجانب التركي من الجانب الامريكي
الحديث عن عمليه التي جرت او توسيع دائره
العمليات من قبل الجانب التركي مربوط
بموقف امريكي في المنطقه وبالتالي كيف ذلك
اوكي
تعرفون ان حسب الاتحاد الديمقراطي
الكردستاني وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه هذه
المجموعات لديها اسلحه متقدمه وبالتالي
عندما نعاين الوضع السوري داعش تقريبا
السبب الذي يدفع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
لتزويد هذه المنظمات
بمنظمات متقدمه بما في ذلك مضاده للصواريخ
وبالتالي يجب ان نفهم ان المنطقه في غايه
التعقيد وهناك سيطره من قبل حزب العمال
الكردستاني وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه او
حسب الاتحاد
وبالتالي للتوصلي الى خلاص نحن بحاجه الى
مقاربه شامله اي مقاربه تستثني الاتراك
وتستثني العرب والتركمان والاكراد هذا لن
ياتي بالسلام الى المنطقه ولكن دعونا
نعاين ما يحصل في سوريا حسب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
قامت بقتل وتعذيب واعتقالي السياسيين
الذين لا يفكرون بنفس الطريقه وبالتالي
هذه المنظمات لا تمثل الاكراد في المنطقه
بالاضافه الى ذلك
يوسف اسال عنها ضيفه
يتعلق هل المشهد كما يبدو همم للناس
الحكومه التركيه في مقابل مكونات كرديه ام
ان هناك
مسار اخر جهات اخرى فئات اخرى ايضا لها
راي مختلف في ما يتعلق بطبيعته هذا
العلاقه سيد حسين
لا ابدا المشهد ليس كما يعني يطوف على سطح
الالام تركيا ليست مقابل
المكونات المنطقه ولكن مكونات المنطقه هي
ضحايا العمليات العسكريه يعني ااا
نظر الكرديه للتعامل حزب العماري مع تركيا
هي نظره خلق رائع خاصه للحزب هو لا يمثل
الكرد الحزب مفروض على الكورد بقوه السلاح
خلق لنفسه حاضنه قسريه وحول المنطقه الى
يعني
التجنيد اذا اذا ما ما ما شاهدنا اذا ما
رجعنا ما يجري في المناطق الكرديه سنرى
بان بيئات الاف القرد تهجر بسبب السياسات
الحزب وتركيا تقوم بقصف المنطق وتزيد
الطين بالله اذا ما ما القينا نظره على
المنطقه ايضا وده سنلاحظ عشرات
المقابر التي كانت يعني كما يرى ابناء
المنطقه هي من
بس سياسات الحزب ولذلك على تركيا ان توجد
حل اخر يمكن لتركيا من خلال اتصالاتها مع
جهاء اجهزه الاستخبارات الايرانيه شكرا
الوقت
سيد حسين شلبي الباحث في الشان الكردي
وكذلك الشكر لضيفي السيد يوسف الافاده
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي التركي
[موسيقى]
اتهمت وكاله الطاقه النوويه الاوكرانيه
روسيا بقصف في محطه النوويه وقالت الوكاله
ان اثني عشره ضربه على الاقل سجلت في موقع
المحطه وان روسيا تعرض العالم باسره للخطر
لكنه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان القوات
الاخرانيه شنت قصف المدفعيا على محطه
النوويه تسبب في اضرار بالمحطه وخطوط لنقل
الكهربائي اليها واتهم المتحدث باسم
الوزاره
هدفها احداث كارثه نوويه
الهادفه لخلق تهديد بوقوعه كارثه في محطه
النوويه خلال اليوم الماضي اطلقت مدفعيه
القوات الاوكرانيه 11 قديفه المدفعيه من
العيار الثقيل على المحطه كما كصفتها
مرتين اليوم في فتره الصباح تم اطلاقه
اثنت 10 قذيفه مدفعيه انفجرت حول وحدات
الطاقه بعد ذلك اطلقت قذفتان اصابتا خط
الكهرباء الذي يغذي المحطه قواتنا ردت
بتدمير موقع اطلاق نيران العدو في مستوطنه
مارجانيس بمقاطعه ديني برو بتوفيسك الوضع
الاشعاعي في المحطه ما زال طبيعيه سيتم
توضيح عواقب الاضرار الناجمه عن القصف بعد
فحص المحطه من قبل خبراء الوكاله الدوليه
لطاقه الذريه ومؤسسه روسوم
وكاله الدولي لطاقه الذريه رافاييل روسي
ان قصف محطه الظفروجيه النوويه غير مقبول
وانه يجب ان يتوقف على الفور وجدد روسي
دعوته لاطراف في النزاع الى انشائي منطقه
امان حول المنطقه
ولا تنفذ عمليات قصف منها
سيمبا
على امتداده اطوار حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
شكلت محطه الزفاروجي النوويه محطه بارزه
ضمن سلسله احداثها واحداثها وظهر التركيز
الروسي عليها منذ الايام العشره الاولى
للحرب في التقرير التالي قراءه في تطور
مسار الاحداث المتعلقه بهذه البحر
منذ الايام الاولى للحرب تجلت الى اهميه
الاستراتيجيه لمحطه زبرج النوويه الاكبر
في اوروبا والعاشره على مستوى العالم
فساعه القوه الروسيه الى اعلان السيطره
الكامله عليها في الرابع من اذار مارس ظلت
رغم ذلك شركه
مرافق المحطه تكررت في محيطها حاله القصف
وتبادل الروس والاوكرانيون الاتهامات بشان
ذلك الى ان قدمت الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا شهر اغسطس مقترحا طالبتا فيه
موسكو باقامه منطقه منزوعه السلاح حول
زبرجها لم يهدئ ضجيج الحرب في محيط المحطه
رغم التحذيرات الدوليه فارسلت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في بدايه شهر
سبتمبر فريق خبراء على راسه مديرها
رافاييل روسي عائلنا الوضع داخل المحطه
واعلن عقب ذلك ان السلامه الماديه
نتيجه تعرضها لقصف متكرر
اعلنت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بعد
ثلاثه ايام من هذا التصريح ان محطه تزب
روجيه قد فصلت عن اخر خط كان يربطها
بالشبكه الكهربائيه في تطور اللافته
للاحداث داخلها
تطورت الاحداث السريعا من الجانب الروسي
فوقع الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين في الخامس من
اكتوبر مرسوما يقضي بنقل ملكيه محطه
زابروجيه الى بلاده في اعقاب اعلان روسيا
ضم اربع مقاطعه اوكرانيه الى الاتحاد
الروسي من بينها مقاطعه زبرجيا لم تمر
ساعات على صدور القرار الروسي الجديد حتى
بدات حشود القوات الاوكرانيه بالتمركز على
محور محطه زبوجيا وصف الروس حينها
التعزيزات الاوكرانيه على خطوط التماس في
المنطقه بانها الاكبر من نوعها منذ بدا
الحرب
عادت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بعد
ذلك للتحذير والتاكيد على ضروره انشاء
منطقه امنه حول المحطه قال مدير الوكاله
يومها ان الاوضاع وصلت الى نقطه يتفق فيها
جميع على ضروره فعل ذلك في اقرب وقت ممكن
في العشرين من نوفمبر اعلنت شركه اينرجو
اتوما الاوكرانيه تعرض منشات البنيه
التحتيه لمحطه زبرجيا للقذف اكثر من اثنتي
عشره مرات خلال يوم واحد ومره اخرى تبادل
الروس والاوكرانيون الاتهامات بشان ذلك
[موسيقى]
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه لصله الضوء على
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لمحطه خروجها ونسال
ضيف الحصاد عن اسباب المخاوف المتعلقه
بقصف المحطه
قال ابي خيل ابو دنيا كبير المستشارين
رئيس الاوكراني ان محاوله اقناعي بلاده
بالتفاوض بعد سلسله انتصارات العسكريه
كبرى حققتها هي دعوات غريبه وترقى الى حد
طلب استسلام اوكرانيا
حدثت كيف على التفكير في الحوار مع الروس
لانهاء النزاع
تتعاقب انتصارات اوكرانيا الميدانيه
فيرتفع لدى ساستها منسوب الثقه بامكانيه
حسم الحرب عسكريا غير ان تطلعات كيف الى
النصر لم تعد تصطدم بقوه روسيا وحسب وانما
ايضا بدعوات من حلفائها تطالبها بالتفاوض
مع الروس والبحث عن تسويه سياسيه
انها دعوات تثير الريبه والاستغراب بل
وترقى الى حد مطالبه اوكرانيا بالاستلام
يقول كبير مستشاري الرئيس
مقترحات مثل لن تتمكن من القيام بكل شيء
بالوسائل العسكريه على اي حاجه فانت بحاجه
الى التفاوض ذلك يعني ان الدوله التي
تستعد اراضيها يجب ان تستسلم للدوله التي
تخسر
انها اوضح لااتي كيف واقواها مظاهرات اولى
الدعوات الى الحوار وكانت بالاساس دعواتنا
امريكيه ابرزها الاسبوع الماضي عندما
استبعد رئيس اركان الجيش الامريكي الجنرال
مارك ميلي قدره اوكرانيا على دفع القوات
الروسيه خارج ارضها بالقوه وعليه يتوجب
استثمار انتصارات كيف الحاليه والانهاك
الروسي لفتح نافذه لمفاوضات تنهي النزاع
ورغم نفي واشنطن مرارا ممارسه اي ضغوط على
الجانب الاوكراني فان محاولات ترويض كيف
ترتبط في الكواليس بمساعنا امريكيه للحفاظ
على تماسك الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا بعد
تنام المخاوف في اوروبا خاصه من اطاله امد
الحرب
وتفاقم تاثيراتها الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه الهائله وفي مجبل الاحوال يجزم
الخبراء في مراكز البحث انا لحظه الاحتكام
للدبلوماسيه ستاتي قطعا لكن ليس قبل
اوانها وحتى ذلك الحين يتعين على الجميع
السماح لديناميكيه الميدان
بتشكيل شروط التفاوض
معنا من واشنطن
المستشار السابق بوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
ومن كيف قسطنطين هيرشيكو وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه السابق اهلا بضيفيه الكريمين
قسطنطينيه لماذا تعتبر كياب هذه الدعوه
والتفاوض مع جانب الروسي استسلام خاصه من
حلفاء كياب من اهم حلفائها وهي واشنطن
دراسه في الحقيقه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن
ثلاثه انواع من المفاوضات قيد النقاش الان
اولا وقف اطلاق النار
ثانيا مفاوضات للسلام
وثا قبول الاستسلام لسوء الحظ ليس لدينا
اي مؤشرات من الجانب الروسي انهم على
جاهزيه للمناقشه باي شيء باستثناء وقف
اطلاق النار والاستسلام ووقت اطلاق النار
سوف يحقق هدف الاستسلام وهذا ليس بالامر
الذي يقبله الشعب الاوكراني او القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه خصوصا الان عندما نرى
ان روسيا ليس لديها المعنويات على مستوى
القوات المسلحه وليس لديها القوه العسكريه
والقدره العسكريه لفرد ارادتها على
اوكرانيا في هذه اللحظه همم خصوصا وان
اوكرانيا تحظى بدعم الخلفاء في الغرب نحن
لا نتحدث عن حرب لبقاء اوكرانيا
والاستقلال اوكرانيا بل نتحدث عن مساله
مبدا
ونحن نتحدث عن بلد
يود ان يفرض همم
لا ياخذ بعين الاعتبار كل العناصر التي
تؤدي الى الامن او الحفاظ على الامن
والسلامه بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه سيد
سيد رئيس ساعود لك سيد قسطنطينيه ضيفي من
واشنطن السيد ماثيو باعتقادك عندما تدعو
واشنطن هؤلاء اكياب اكياف لفتح نافذه
للتفاوض مع الجانب الروسي هل هناك تصور ما
لهذه النافذه لهذا التفاوض الذي يعتبره
الجانب الاوكراني بانه دعوه للاستسلام
المتحده الامريكيه فيه الكثير من التفاصيل
والتعقيد اولا تود واشنطن ان تنظر
اوكرانيا في امكانيه التفاوض ولكن كما قال
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي منذ اسبوعا
او اكثر ما يمكن ان تقوم به الولايات
المتحده لمساعدته اوكرانيا هو مساعده
اوكرانيا على تحسين موقفها
العسكري في الميدان وكل ما كانت اقوى في
الميدان زادت قوه الموقف التفاضلي
ولكن معظم الحروب تنتهي بحل تفاضليه وعلى
الارجح هذه الحرب سوف تنتهي على نفس النسب
والنقطه الثالثه والاخيره هناك خطر بان
روسيا يمكن ان تنظر الى العالم
وكانها او تبدو للعالم وكانها بلد يدعو
الى السلام والمفاوضات لانها بالفعل ادعت
للحصول ذلك وتبدا اوكرانيا بمظهر الدوله
المعاديه لهذا الامر لذلك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تسلط الضوء على هذا
الموضوع النيه
بالحديث والتفاوض من خلال حمله علاقات
عامه وبالتالي لتلخيص الموقف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تود ان تكون اوكرانيا
منفتحه على التفاوض ولكن في الوقت نفسه
تعرف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان ال
تكسب اوكرانيا معركه في الميدان يحقق هذا
هذا
ولكن القاده في موسكو يقولون القرار في
واشنطن عندما تريد واشنطن انهاء هذه الحرب
انها سوف تنهيها بالضغط على اكياس
ان هذا غير صحيح نحن نتحدث عن اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا هي للاوكرانيين والاوكرانيون
يقررون مدى القتال الذي سوف يؤخذ
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه قالت ان
المفاوضات بشان اوكرانيا لن تجرع من دوني
وجود اوكراني على طويله المفاوضات نعم
الولايات المتحده لديها بعض الاوراق بما
في ذلك الدعم العسكري ولكن اوكرانيا هي من
يقود هذه المعركه واوكرانيا هي تقاتل في
سبيل الحريه
المبادره او هذه الدعوه من قبل واشنطن
وهؤلاء وحلفاء كياب لفتح نافذه للتفاوض هل
ستؤثر على الموقف العسكري الحالي
فاين
لابسه فيه ما هو الموقف الاوكراني بالنسبه
الى المفاوضات
ولذلك نحن نرى ان روسيا بحاجه الى قبول
القواعد الاساسيه
للقوانين الدوليه بنسبه الى المفاوضات اذا
ما كانت تشمل خروج القوات الروسيه من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه كيف يحصل ذلك
وكيف يمكن ان يستخدم وقف اطلاق النار ليس
لاطاله امه الحرب بل للعوده الى ما يشبه
الامر الطبيعي هذا بالتحديد ما توده
اوكرانيا ان تنخرط به هناك خطه من عشر
نقاط
اعلن عنها الرئيس الاوكراني بشكل واعتقده
انها تشكل اساسا جيدا ولكن يبدو ان روسيا
لا تقبل بهذه الخطه
وبالتالي هناك رساله من اوكرانيا نحن على
استعدادا للتفاوض ولكن التفاوض يحصل على
اساسا مقبولا لاوكرانيا
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني طبعا سابقا وكذلك
الشكر لضيفي من واشنطن الماضي المستشار
السابق بوزاره الدفاع الامريكي
[موسيقى]
عوده الى تبادل الاتهامات بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
انه يكتب السيطره عليها قوه موسكو في جنوب
اوكرانيا ما الذي حدث فقوله الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان اكثر من 10
انفجارات هزت اكبر محطه للطاقه النوويه في
اوروبا مساء امس السبت واليوم الاحد تقول
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان اوكرانيا اطلقت
قذائف على خطوط الكهرباء في المحطه في حين
ذكرته تارس الروسيه للانباء ان بعض منشات
التخزين في الموقع تعرضت لقذف الاوكراني
ونقلت عن رنات كارتشا مستشار الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه الطاقه النوويه الروسيه
قوله ابن القذائف اطلقت بالقرب من مستودع
للنفايات النوويه الجافه ومبنى فيه كميات
جديده من الوقود النووي المستنثر اما شركه
الطاقه النوويه الاخرانيه اليرجوطهم فقد
اتهمت الجيش دي بقصف محطه زفوجيا وقالت ان
منشات البنيه التحتيه بالمحطه تعرضت لما
لا يقل عن اثتين عشره ضربه وقالت الشركه
ان روسيا استهدفت البنيه التحتيه الضروريه
لاعاده تشغيل وحدات في المحطه في محاوله
لعرقله عمليه انتاج الطاقه وسد الاحتياجات
الاوكرانيه ما حدث امس واليوم دفع مدير
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رفائل
بروسلي الى التحذير من كارثه نوويه وتوجيه
رساله لاطراف النزاع قال فيها انتم تلعبون
بالنار لكن ما اسبابها هذا القلق
هناك مخاوف من احتمال وقوعه حادث خطير على
بعد خمسه كيلومترات فقط من موقعي اسوء
حادث النووي في العالم وهو كارثه تشيرنبل
عام
ونقلا عن معلومات من اداره المحطه قال
فريق الوكاله الدولي للطاقه الذريه هناك
ان ادار لحقت ببعض المباني والانظمه
والمعدات في الموقع وقد ادى القصف الاخير
الى اغلاق مفعلات المحطه لكنه هناك خطرا
من ارتفاع درجه حراره الوقود النووي اذا
قطع التيار الكهربائي الذي يشغل انظمه
التبريد بقي ان يشير الى ان زفاره اكبر
منشاه نوويه في اوروبا وهي الاهم من بين
اربع محطات للطاقه النوويه في اوكرانيا
توفروا مجتمعه حوالي نصف الكهربائي في
البلاد
وتكتسي محطه اهميه الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه
قولي انها تبعد حوالي 200 كم فقط عن شبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام
عن هذه المحطه معنا من فينا طارق رؤوف وهو
الرئيس السابق لمكتب التحقيقات وسياسه
الامن في الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذري ست
طارق عندما نتكلم عن
محطه بهذه الاهميه وبهذه الخطوره
ما الحسابات التي من خلالها استطيع ان
نفهم ما الذي يجري في هذه المحطه من
التهابات متبادله بين الطرفين كل الطرفين
الطرف الاخر بانه هو من يستهدف بضرب وقذف
هذه المحطه
الحقيقه
مفاعلات وهي الاكبر في اوروبا
ومدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قال
اليوم ان القصف لحق بهذا الموقع بشكل كبير
واشار الى ضرر في مركز التبريد النووي
باضافه الى معدات اخرى يوم غد صباحا
الفريق الوكاله الذي فيه خبراء في المكان
سوف يقدمه سوف يرفع تقريرا ولكن المدير
حتى الاطراف على وقف القصف وعلى ضروره
انشائي منطقه امنه محيطه بمحطه قريش
جسر رابط مباشره بين هذه المحطه محطه
الصفا روجيه وما جرى في السنوات الماضيه
يتعلق
بالشيرنوبيل لو حدث لا قدر الله وانت
تعرضت هذه المحطه لخطر حقيقي
او اي قذف الاسبوع الماضي شاهدنا الحادث
الذي ادى الى السقوط
صاروخ عن طريق الخطا في بولندا وبالتالي
الخطر مرتفع السؤال هو من يقصف محطه
هل هم الاشخاص الذين احتلوا المحطه بشكل
غير قانوني او الجهه التي تحاول اعاده او
استعاده السيطره على هذه المحطه الاجابه
معروفه ولكن ما من احد يود ان يتحدث عن
ذلك بشكل
الاعلام يجب ان تطلب من قياده الوكاله
الدولي اعتقدريه ان تتحلى بالشفافيه بنسبه
الى القصف تقول بان الجهه معروفه التي
تستهدف هذه المحطه بصواريخها
بس معروف ولكن لي اسباب السياسيه لا يودون
ان يفضح عنها بشكل علني ولكن الاشاره
اليها تتم بين الاوساط الدبلوماسيه هنا
حتى وان كان الامر يتعلق بمحطه بهذه
الخطوره ليس فقط على اوكرانيا وروسيا ولكن
على كامل اوروبا ومع ذلك يتم التكتم عن من
يقصف ويقوم باستهداف هذه المحطه
بليز الحقيقه هذا موضوع عن حساس على
المستوى السياسي اعتقد ان لو انا قد ان
لكي تكون شفافين ومنفتحين بالنسبه الى هذا
الموضوع
والمدير يتحدث عن منطقه امنه باضافه الى
قرار صدر على مستوى الوكاله في الاسبوع
الماضي ولكن ما من شيء تغير والقذف مستمر
لذلك نحن وكاننا ننتظر لكي يحدث حادث ماء
سيء يؤدي الى خطر اشعاع في المنطقه
المحيطه بالمحطه فيما يتعلق بعنصر الامان
في هذه المحطه هل هذه المحطه همم مؤمنه
ايا كان نوع الصواريخ ام لا
المحطات النوويه غير مصممه كي تقاوم اذا
ما صح التعبير قصفا صاروخيا يمكنها ان
تقاوم اطلاق بالاسلحه الخفيفه ولكننا
نتحدث عن سنتيمترات من الاسمنت
وايضا الحديد الصلب ولكن تبعا لنوعي
الصاروخ يمكن اي صاروخ ان يخترق المحطه
ولا نود ان ننتظر هكذا حادث او ان نمتحن
قوه المفعل وما اذا كان باستطاعته ان
يتحمل قصفا صاروخيا او مدفعيا
الوكاله التي تتكلم على ان ال ال القصف
هذه المره وصل الى الى اماكن خطيره جدا
يعني ما الذي يعني ذلك
التقرير او التقرير الاخير الذي نشره
المدير اليوم تحدث عن ضرر
لتخزين محطه تخزين باضافه الى محطه تبريد
وكابل كهربائي لاحد المفاعلات الاربعه
بالاضافه الى همم محطات او نقطه التخزين
لنظام التبريد سوف تنشر شكرا شكرا لك سيد
طارق رؤوف الرئيس السابق لمكتب التحقق
وسياسه الامن في الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه قد ادركنا الوقت